he's clearly gotten to be a better
magician but i i think he's kind of
grown in a lot of ways
he's he's definitely better at his job
he's he's more focused he's more
professional uh but you know all those
elements that make him jimmy wu are
still there you know he's still
very earnest very sweet uh uh you know
he still
uh wants to divulge a lot of information
about his
his life and make connections to people
and
all those things that make him jimmy are
still there but
but he is obviously uh you know a better
agent
that's why he's here on this case how'd
you do it scott
do what the card trick
james ewoo fbi hi randall how are you
i'm good how are you i love your sweater
it's so cute
oh thank you thank you keeping warm the
first time i ever interviewed you
or the only time i've ever interviewed
interviewed you was at d23
when it was announced you were gonna be
in one division and i i have to admit it
was one of the more challenging
interviews i've had because i couldn't
wrap my head around
what the hell the show was
i know i'm so sorry how was the show
presented to you and what did you know
about it before you read a script
when it was presented to me well when i
first found out that i'd be coming back
into the mcu i knew nothing
all i knew was that you know [ __ ] they
only jimmy wu was gonna
you know they wanted jimmy woo for this
show and i was on disney plus and i was
like absolutely i'm there
and then um and then maybe a few days
later they called me into the marvel
uh studios offices and in the conference
room jack schaefer the head writer
broke down the entire series uh
to me and there were pictures all around
the walls of this conference room
there's timelines and
and graphs and all you know it was very
uh
very thorough and i was just blown away
i was just blown away i i mean because i
felt like it was so unusual
so so so different from anything that's
ever been done on tv
and um but i also wondered like how are
they gonna do this
this is like this is so so
like challenging us and then and then uh
and then you know later i got the
a hold of the scripts once we you know
started gearing into production
and i was i was just as in it as the
fans are right now in terms of like i
had the same questions as we were going
through it i
you know i was uh just as excited
excited to read the next episode and to
you know
see how this all would unfold and uh uh
and yeah and and after reading the the
final script i was like
oh okay oh okay so that's the face you
made
okay that's the face i made well
throughout the throughout those
you know throughout reading the scripts
they were constant oh
oh that's it okay that makes sense and
you know
and then it all kind of it all it all uh
makes sense in the end what was the
biggest question that you had coming
into the show
come the biggest question that i had
mm-hmm
[Music]
do you know if you were blipped that was
a question that i did have
that was my biggest one i got a clear
answer on that but my guess is
probably not you know because he has he
has grown you know in in these five
years he has
he's gotten to be such a better magician
so he has to have been working on it you
know all those fights that one card
trick all those five years
um but i don't know my guess is though
that he wasn't
lived what are we looking at here is it
an alternate reality
time travel some cockamamie social
experiment it's a sitcom
a 1950 sitcom but why he's kind of like
the liaison for the audience right now
he's asking all the questions that we're
asking he's writing everything on the
whiteboard we're like yep we want to
know that we want to know that we want
to know that
so will we get the answers to most of
these questions by the end of the season
um uh i'll i'll i'll say uh yeah
i will say yeah that that it does start
to make sense and and
the answers will will uh reveal
themselves
well we're having so much fun with the
easter eggs and i know i'm sure you've
been asked about this all day but fans
were
loving the close-up magic that you
learned the trick
did you learn it for real yes yes i did
that was not cgi i did that
i think i think i had a couple days on
it or a week learning that trick and you
know it was just about dexterity you
know and and uh
working those finger muscles and and i
think by the time we got to set i think
i
i think i had mastered it at that point
i was gonna say you know we're kind of
in the lockdown times where we're all
picking up skills so now are you just
like focused on
um close-up magic at all or no you know
what i
after the shoot i kind of stopped
thinking about it but that's a good idea
because i
am fascinated by it and i do want to
learn more and and if by
you know the grace of god they bring
jimmy wu back it would be nice to have
more tricks under my sleeve
i don't know if you saw there was this
pretty viral tweet over the weekend
um from stephen sean ford that said hear
me out an entire disney plus show about
jimmy wu
dues working cases in the mcu like a fun
x-files make it happen and it
it kind of blew up so i don't know if
you saw that or what you think about it
nobody sent me that
somebody said i'm not on social media
but somebody sent me that and
i thought this is brilliant i would love
it i would do it in a heartbeat
uh you know i i don't have any say in
this but i'm glad it's out there
you know i feel like if we start
manifesting it you know yes yes that's
right that's right
work the momentum you never know you
never know
yeah and he's kind of like he's he's got
this web of connections to kind of all
of these mcu characters at this point
and the future is so bright for marvel
we have this whole new phase in the
works so
if who who do you want to like team up
with next where do you want to go next
because right now you're working with
monica rambo so
captain marvel 2 is a possibility doctor
strange is a possibility like where do
you want to be
uh you know i don't i don't know and i
don't care
as long as i'm there you know it's on
there i would love to
i would love to work with other
superheroes in the mcu
i would love to uh uh you know
have that that x-files type of show i
would love to
such a good idea i'd love to be in the
background uh
with no lines just as long as i'm there
i'm happy
no you deserve more um have you heard
anything about third ant-man if you if
you'll be
heading back to the west coast i have
not i have not
uh i know they're they're they're
working on it but i'm not sure if i'm in
it or not but you know one case at a
time i am focused on on on westview
i love seeing you and darcy come
together what was the moment that you
realized that
darcy and jimmy would work so well as a
duo
oh gosh i mean just doing those scenes
with her
with cats innings was uh i you know when
when you're having fun
acting with a partner uh you know it and
i i feel like that fun that fun it shows
you can you can feel it when you see the
scene
and it may not be a fun scene but you
could just feel it in the actors if
there's this energy about them
and and for me personally i mean just
working with kat was so fun
because she is so cool and so so nice
and so
talented and so funny and it was just a
joy to work off of her
yeah there's there's so many theories
about the show right now
have you seen one yet that you think is
scarily close to being accurate
yes okay so someone out there is on the
money
yes i've seen some that are uh that are
uh uh remarkably close and make me kind
of
uh you know it's a testament to these
fans that
you know they they understand this
universe better than i do you know for
them to
to be able to figure these things out ah
well i'm out of time but you're a
delight and um yeah
can't wait to talk to you more about
this yeah i'm looking forward to it one
day
yeah congrats again love the sweater and
thank you thank you guys that means a
lot
i love your sweater too